blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman welcome to the show let's
start with the latest updates from the
january 6th committee this is different
than the january 6th commission remember
the commission was going to be this big
bipartisan
commission to investigate the trump
rights which would include
five republicans chosen by republicans
and five democrats chosen by democrats
you'd have a democratic chair and a
republican vice chair and they'd have to
sign off on every subpoena and it was
all going to be great except republicans
said no no no because they wanted it to
include looking into things like when
steve scalise was shot in i think it was
2017
and the george floyd protests and things
that really had nothing to do with the
trump trump riots so that didn't happen
and eventually we got the committee that
um had four police officers capital
police officers testify about a month
ago and it's now continuing to move
forward and the new battle lines on this
appear to be requests for documents from
donald trump and donald trump is
panicking and donald trump is desperate
to hide those documents former president
donald trump has called the select
committee investigating the january 6
capital riot a partisan shame
remember that it is what it is because
republicans refuse to participate in the
original big commission
and suggested that he will invoke
executive privilege as the committee
seeks a trove of documents
trump issued a statement on wednesday
slamming the leftist committee after it
sent its first request for documents
relating to the events of january 6th
these requests included communications
with
within and among the white house and
executive branch agencies the committee
is chaired by democratic representative
benny thompson and includes republican
representatives liz cheney and adam
kinzinger both critics of the former
president
trump's statement said the leftist
select committee has further exposed
itself as a partisan sham and waste of
taxpayer dollars with a request that's
timed to distract americans from
historic and global catastrophes brought
on by the failures of joe biden and the
democrats unfortunately this partisan
exercise is being performed at the
expense of long-standing legal
principles of privilege
executive privilege will be defended not
just on my behalf on behalf of my
administration and the patriots who
worked beside me but on behalf of the
office of the president of the united
states and the future of our nation
everything's delusions of grandeur
these democrats only have one entire
trick political theater and their latest
request only reinforces the pathetic
reality so the the reading here is
um trump is desperate
not to have any documents related to him
or his administration
uh presented
to the committee now he may well succeed
or at least tie this up in court long
enough that it goes absolutely nowhere
and that's
uh that that's disturbing uh more on
this from cnn which wrote the biden
administration has already declined to
assert executive privilege over some
testimony related to january 6.
telling former justice department
officials they were free to provide
unrestricted testimony but the
administration has not weighed in on
whether the committee should have
unrestricted access to records and
documents from the trump white house the
document requests from the house select
committee echo those previously issued
by other house committees in the
aftermath of the january 6 riot while
significantly broadening the search to
other areas and people inside and
outside government specifically the
select committee is asking for records
from the department of justice interior
defense office of the director of
national intelligence fbi
national counterterrorism center
department of homeland security and
perhaps most importantly the national
archives the custodian of the trump
administration white house records now
as has been the case with donald trump
for years
if you really believed you were not
guilty of what you're being accused or
suspected
you would want documents to come out
which would prove your innocence if you
believe you've done nothing wrong when
it comes to your taxes you would want
given all of the ways in which not
releasing your taxes has dragged you
down you would want it to come out that
everything's fine with your taxes this
is fundamentally not the way
an innocent person behaves and
unfortunately because of the way things
have gone and i know every time i'm real
with the with the audience somebody gets
mad and says david you're you're not
you're you should be telling us it's all
going to happen i think there's a really
good chance that donald trump prevents
these documents from being presented to
the committee
or delays it long enough that it won't
matter
or makes it so that they're they are
redacted documents or whatever the case
may be i i unfortunately think that it's
completely plausible that that may be
the way that it goes so we're going to
continue covering the january 6th
committee
if there are committee events and
testimony
that you think i should cover i may miss
it i'm trying to keep an eye on a lot of
different scheduling things biden stuff
trump stuff hearings all these different
things feel free to shoot an email to
info davidpakman.com when the four
police officers testified
it was
very informative and very illuminating
and worth worth covering live so let me
know if you see any of that
i want to go through with you today a
few different clips of the
extraordinarily childish
humiliating anti-mask tantrums that
we're seeing around the country on
yesterday's show i had coverage of this
anti-vaccine mandate rally in new york
city
and it was crazy there are also now more
and more school districts as school has
already started for the fall in some
places and is within a week or two of
starting in other places there are more
and more places that are um now having
hearings school board hearings of
various kinds and there are furious
parents showing up and saying no masks
for my kids now i'm not going to belabor
this point but i've made it before and
i've tweeted about it and many of you
seem to agree
i'm imagining if i'm a nine-year-old
in school
and i am told
there are going to be
mask requirements in school but don't
worry little johnny
i'm going to go crazy
demanding they not force you to wear a
mask
i think that the wearing of the mask
wouldn't be that bad compared to knowing
my mom is going cuckoo for coco puffs on
zoom meetings and at a school board
meeting right i think that that would be
far worse for the kid but at the end of
the day i am not a parent so i guess i
can't say for sure but that's certainly
my instinct let's take a look at some
examples here is an anti-master at the
shenandoah i know that the word is
probably it's the root of it seems to be
the same as shenandoah but it's the
different spelling i believe it's
pronounced shenandoah central school
district meeting
uh in new york maybe it is just
pronounced shenandoah even though it's
spelled in a way i've not seen before
okay in any case here is
some crazy scenario where a parent says
um it's possible that the masks will
lead to sexual assault my guess is that
they they say because you wouldn't know
who it is because they're wearing it
let's say your son or daughter is about
to become that 10 statistic they're
being led down the hallway by the rapist
they're walking casually on by passing
students and teachers along the way the
students and teachers are smiling at the
soon-to-be victim behind their mask but
nobody can see the smile they disappear
and your child is violently raped
what we didn't know is that the rapist
had told your child that if he or she
said a word to anyone as they were
walking they would kill them
what we didn't know is that your son or
daughter
excuse me i was smart enough to mouth
the words help me
because they were being led away
oh i see and so if they're wearing a
mask they wouldn't be able to mouth that
all the while we were smiling at this
victim behind our mask the victim was
trying to communicate their distress to
us without the use of vocal words
we failed their son or daughter in those
moments and they were raped
we could have stopped such a violent act
from occurring but our choice to be
complicit
it's it's it's kind of like a weird
disaster porn i mean that's an insanely
specific scenario i don't i don't know
really what to make of it other than
if you have to come up with such crazy
scenarios to justify why
just the kids shouldn't all wear masks
to prevent the spread especially since
they're mostly not vaccinated yet
you're probably reaching beyond what
makes sense is sort of my instinct
here's another one this is an
anti-massacre at higley unified school
district in gilbert arizona the video is
very dark i don't know why it's just the
video we have and she says science is
ridiculous i can't figure out by now
the science is ridiculous then you're
probably driving around in your car with
a mask on by yourself and i can't help
you at this point nor do i want to it's
not my job i appreciate what you want to
do for you and your family i would
appreciate it if you respected what i
did for me and my family because that's
where we live the united states of
america god bless america
the end thank you
and i am as disturbed by
the applause that this stuff gets
uh as i am by the content of it and just
really funny thing the the woman sort of
has a look like roseanne barr
and uh roseanne barr's former uh former
husband tom arnold who's a supporter of
the david pakman show the first response
on twitter is i swear roseanne used to
be funny um but this is this is really
really bad really really bad and
unfortunately the amount of support it
gets is maybe the scariest uh the
scariest part altogether and then lastly
here here's an anti-massacre that
completely loses his mind
at a meeting of the board of
commissioners in ottawa county michigan
let's listen to that dan vanderswag
here comes dan
that's my father-in-law right there
speaking on behalf of my his
grandkids you with that diaper on your
face if he farted right now could you
smell it that's how stupid this is
we're all playing games here with
people's lives
now let me address that because there's
this is a talking point that's been
spreading and it's it's spreading uh
not intentionally using a pun this is a
talking point that's been floating
around which is is the if you can smell
something through the mask as the as the
gentleman here astutely points out and
and decorously points out
if you can smell a fart through the mask
then it couldn't really be protecting
you from covid
this is this is actually so simple
the smell from a fart
is caused by um some version of methane
i think it's called like methanthiol or
something like that
and
you know like sulfur-containing
molecules the point is the the molecules
that contain the fart smell are really
really small they're way smaller than
coronavirus coronavirus droplets are up
to 34 000 percent larger than fart smell
carrying molecules so it's such a stupid
topic but at the same time it keeps
getting repeated if you can smell
through the mask clearly it's doing
nothing no no no let's look at the size
of the molecules and of course the knit
of the mask also makes a difference
let's listen to a little more of this
guy and i'm sick of it i would represent
all these hard-working guys that
couldn't be here today
just
take off work to put up with this bs
that you guys are putting down
and there's hell coming
there's hell coming and i'm not doing it
to threaten anybody but there's a lot of
good guys out there ready to do bad
things soon
watch what's coming
not him he would never do that stuff
he's not threatening us but he's just
letting us know other people might do
stuff if they have to wear mandates are
against the nuremberg codes
uh oh now it's gone completely off the
first line states
voluntarily informed consent
all right i can't even i can't even
listen to any more of that so that's
what's going on and if these people put
five percent of the energy into helping
to end the pandemic that they put into
things that would help prolong it uh we
might be out of it by now
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at dpakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the show remember that
our primary source of funding is people
who sign up for memberships at
joinpackman.com you'll get an extra show
every day as well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
and it just feels good to do go to
joinpacman.com
and sign up today let's hear from some
folks in the audience we do this now via
discord you can uh join up at
davidpakman.com
discord the waiting lobby is where you
go if you would like to be put on the
air
let's start today
with matt from virginia matt from
virginia you are
on the air
and um would love to hear from you
matt from virginia you are on the air
matt
i guess no matt from virginia
let's try oh i don't know how about
kevin from seattle
kevin from seattle you are next up
go ahead
yes
oh oh awesome thanks so much for taking
my call um
i have a question but before i get to my
question i first want to say that
um
that your content your content creations
is proficient having followed you for at
least a year and
keep up the good work
thank you
with that said i have been following um
left
left content creators for
[Music]
probably a few years ever since um kyle
kolinsky said they were talking about
2015 i think that's where they started
politics started following politics and
it it's it's come to my in my um
my awareness that
there are
the in my opinion there are
problems um i've been noticing in um
these
in content creating creators if not the
in this communities of these content
creators mostly
just the insular nature of
them like
like there
there are a lot of these um problems
like for inst for instance
it's difficult it can when i'm listening
to like a content creator
um
what i'm receiving or what i'm hearing
from people within that certain
community like say like say particular
talk for example or let's say to young
turks i'm getting
depe i'm getting just the opinions from
from say the content creators but but
nothing beyond that and it becomes a
little bit difficult to
if when there are outside opinions um
for people with it within a community to
like accept
outside opinions
um
like
we can go over some examples but i think
that
because of my experience i decided to
like
change it up not and i decided to like
read the news instead of following
content creators and since then
um i think my awareness in politics
and current events has expanded and it's
personally um
personally have benefited me
um
that's my question
um i know in
your show you talk about um
media literacy um i was wondering like
for the purposes of not only media
literacy but responsible content
consumption if it's a good idea to like
um
do you think do you think uh cause um
consumers should reduce the dependency
of um
content of
political opinions for or these online
content creators um do you think they
should reduce dependency on that inside
for instance instead of that say they
should just read the news
kevin thank you for the question um i uh
i have said many times before there's
sort of a media consumption pyramid that
i think makes sense i think the base of
the pyramid is really reading nonfiction
books history economics political
philosophy etc that should be the base
of the pyramid
next after that it goes to reading
reports in newspapers and periodicals
and then the top of the pyramid would be
consuming content like mine or that of
others i think that makes for the most
well-rounded media diet where you're
coming into opinion programming like my
show
with a base
of understanding history philosophy
uh political science etc then you are
reading ideally as close as there is to
to just reporting about what's going on
and then you fill that in with with
shows like mine i think that's the
healthiest media diet
it's like like food pyramid so exactly
exactly kevin i've got a ton of people
waiting so i'm gonna let you go i
appreciate that we were able to get to
the question thank you very much
let's go next to
sam
from new york city sam from new york
city you are next up what is on your
mind today my friend
sam from new york city you're on the air
hey can you hear me
now i can
awesome how are you doing i just wanted
to call uh and ask
um another question about
afghanistan i know you've spoken a lot
about it the past few days on the show
yes i'm just wondering
a year from now
what would a successful mission look
like to you
you're saying if we had delayed this for
a year or just what do i think
sorry i'm saying
a lot some stuff's gone right a lot's
gone wrong the past few weeks
if we look ahead to you know the summer
of 2022
given what we've already done
what ideally do you think afghanistan
would look like you know a year from now
if u.s foreign policy is successful
i think that the framing is completely
wrong i think u.s foreign policy has
failed we've been there for 20 years we
did not create
if we believe it was our goal to create
a sustainable
self-governance infrastructure in
afghanistan we failed to do it so u.s
foreign policy has failed the hope for
afghanistan would be
we get out
we deal with evacuating people our
people refugees we figure out how to
empathetically take care of people that
are in a worse situation because we've
been there for 20 years
and then in an ideal world
afghanistan
goes in the opposite direction of being
a failed state it goes in the direction
of being a working state and it there is
peace and there is sensible
self-governance but the idea that we
failed it would be happening despite
american intervention not as a result of
it and i i just disagree with the
framing of that because we our
participation has been a disaster
okay sam from new york city apparently
flummoxed by my uh response and so we're
going to move on
let's go next to christian from
california going to the opposite coast
uh christian from california let's hope
you're unmuted what's on your mind today
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
all right so um i have uh some questions
i guess uh about the way your show has
been
running the past year um i remember
pre-election 2020.
uh you talking about how day one of the
biden administration you would be
doing a lot of content
focused on pulling the biden
administration to the left and
it seems that nowadays your content is
i feel like i'm most of the time i'm at
like a zoo
but rather than looking at animals i'm
looking at like
things conservatives say i was wondering
um
do you ever see yourself maybe
getting back to more
more video and segments focus on like
implementing progressive policy
yes we uh continue to do a mix of things
during the
covid relief bill uh i we were to the
left of joe biden on infrastructure
we've been to the left of joe biden and
you know every day is just uh doing a
mix of different things
and i think we will continue to do that
you know my expectation because this is
the way it's always been is
the mix will always be wrong for a
significant share of the audience so i
try not to be guided too much by that
and basically just do the show i feel
like doing every day that's really
that's really all it is there's no
bigger
um
you know there's no uh
there's no real big influence other than
what's the show i feel like doing today
and that's been the guiding principle
basically since day one
very strongly said thank you for your
time
thank you christian from california very
much appreciated let's keep going let's
go next to i guess it might be rachel or
rach rachel or rache whichever you go by
you are you're on the air what's going
on
rachel you're on the air
all right no rachel that's unfortunate
let's try
instead
zach from st louis i feel like it's been
a while since we've heard from anybody
from uh from st louis
zach from st louis you're on what's
going on today
hey david thanks for uh picking on me um
appreciate everything you do by the way
thank you uh in regards to covid this is
a conversation i've been having
frequently with uh family and friends um
you know taking it back home from
afghanistan for a minute is how do we
come back from this edge we're on you
know there's a there's a set of people
who
and and i've just i've kind of looked at
the anti-mask anti-vaccine people as two
camps okay
the people who are going out of their
way to do everything possible to move
the goal posts and they are never going
to do this and then they're skeptics and
i think with all the uh
the fda approval and modern is on the
horizon for that as well i think that's
going to help a lot of the skeptics but
the people who are anti like
they seem like they'd rather die than
get the shot they put things they don't
even understand what it is in their body
they get this shot
and i i'm completely just gobsmacked
with my family and friends as to how
we unprogram i don't think these people
can be deprogrammed it's a cult but i
don't think they can be deprogrammed and
i just don't know how to bring it back
yeah i mean unfortunately i agree with
you i wish it were different but i did a
segment earlier this week called sorry
guys the trumpets are too far gone um i
i do believe that there were peop some
people who in good faith were saying
if and when this gets full approval i'll
go and get the vaccine to take the
approval issue for a second i think
there were people who in good faith were
saying that and some of them are going
to go now and get vaccinated because it
was fully approved
there are others who are just always
looking for whatever just out of reach
requirement they can put in place to
avoid getting vaccinated i don't think
there's any bringing them back and
unfortunately it is going to lead to
death it's not going to be just their
death it's going to lead to
death among some people who do get
vaccinated but they get infected by
these people anyway because the vaccines
aren't 100 effective i want to be
convinced by someone in the audience
that there actually is something that
can be done to bring these people back i
i don't really
think there is
you one thing that comes to mind
is we can play really dumb childish
reverse psychology with them right like
hypothetically
if it came out that biden was going to
ban the vaccine
i think many of them would say oh i'm
going to go and get it screw biden but
that's very i mean you can't really run
a country that way you know and it's
only those types of ideas that i think
would work to convince them sadly
right and i and i think on in my biggest
fear and i i'm not a pessimist i'm just
a realist and i think this is going to
end in violence unfortunately because i
don't think biden's ever going to come
out and politically suicide himself and
you know may wide mandate you know
federal mandate on the vaccine i think
it'll certainly we're already seeing
like lsu is requiring its uh cvs
corporation is requiring it etcetera
etcetera you'll start to see more and
more of these mandates at the business
and corporate level to kind of squeeze
people more right um
i'm afraid that once we squeeze you know
you back a
injured animal into a corner they're
going to lash out and i feel like it's
only going to end in violence because
they aren't able to be brought back from
that edge i worry that you're right i
hope that you're wrong but i worry that
you're right and right now there's
nobody who's talking me out of this
belief i i increasingly am thinking that
your analysis is spot on let's hope that
we're both wrong you know
no kidding well um yeah that'll do it
for me thank you again for having me on
all right appreciate it perfect audio
perfect question very much uh good to
hear from you let's go next to stephanie
in dallas we're gonna try again in texas
stephanie and dallas you are next up uh
what's on your mind
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
find stephanie fantastic i'm glad you
guys had a wonderful look you had a
great trip in um spain correct yes thank
you yes wonderful and i'm glad you guys
are healthy that's great news um and
actually i called uh in a couple months
ago back when our governor lifted the
mass mandate yes and here we are in
august
and things are looking kind of grim
right yes they are
and i actually agree with the last
caller i had some concerns like they did
too about the um
the
i don't know i kind of feel like there's
a reckoning coming our way unfortunately
and i just have a lot of thoughts i'm
trying to process as i'm sure a lot of
people are right now
and one of the things i wanted to share
with you is that we went to over the
summer my family and i took a little
road trip um from texas up through
uh tennessee and
columbus and we went up to upstate and
then came back down through uh civil war
sites that was our trip it was a lot of
fun but the one thing i really um
responded to on our trip was that um
uh
you know just going through all the
civil war sites especially i think my
favorite was um
what is that harpers ferry and that's
kind of where everything kind of started
and we were listening to podcasts about
it on the way up there and it's just
fascinating but the thing i realized and
the thing that made me so kind of
depressed is that
over 200 years we've been doing what
we're doing and not a lot has changed
unfortunately i think that there's been
little you know rays of hope here and
there but i just feel like it's been
um
you know it's just this pattern it's
been going on and on about people that
the wealthy elite you know
kind of controlling the small the
majority of the people and it's just
it's it's it was
made really
evident in the um
in the history i was kind of gleaning
from everything and oh i see what you're
saying yeah i mean listen
i think you're right about that kind of
superstructure but i think also a lot
has changed um
when you look at
you know everything from the civil
rights movement to technological
advancements to the standard of living
overall i mean obviously you know we
want to be realistic and point to things
that that have improved and things that
haven't but the superstructure you're
pointing out certainly still exists
right and the thing that i mean it's the
thing that to me is so um
disappointing is that since i'm in the
you know in the southwest and i i
fortunately where i live pretty diverse
you know that my community and
where i go and when i go and run my
errands during the day i see a lot of
people still wearing masks so that's
helpful and my family are all vaccinated
so that's you know we're trying to do
our part but i still go out and drive
around i still see people you know with
confederate flags stickers on their
trucks and i'm like yeah you know i
would hope that i don't know and and
that's the thing i'm kind of like not
just with the coved you know um argument
or the
division that people have and just worry
that like
just all the divisiveness it's like it's
starting to become a little too
people are getting a little too
comfortable you know being
upfront about their
their their their you know their racism
and everything i'm just hoping that and
the other thing is i think people are
being people are getting way too
comfortable with the fact that they
think that just disagreeing with all
empirical evidence and science is is
just valid opinion and it's just as
valid as disagreeing about a favorite
color you know that's a real problem
that's an empirical crisis i would say
right yeah 100 and but you know the
other thing from coming from all of this
is that i think i think i'm raising an
activist my daughter's becoming very
radical which is a good thing i'm hoping
that she's going to be you know because
it's up to us as parents to kind of
point our kids in the direction that
we want him to go and i she's like
saying she's gonna start like a little
group at school called the diversity
club and and and i'm hoping that like
through like little little leo
trickle-down things like that that
she'll hopefully be able to
influence other people i don't know i
don't know if she's inviting herself
some more criticism or what but you know
probably both probably both
thanks stephanie i appreciate hearing
from you again thanks you take care
all right there's stephanie in dallas
let's take a quick break i am going to
get back to calls right after this short
break so if you'd still like to chat
don't hang up
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right let's speak to a few more
people via discord you can join at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go next to eva from
boston eva from boston your next up uh
what's going on today what's on your
mind
hi david can you hear me
yes i can
okay great um
so you know i'm having a good day it's
my first time getting on to call you so
i'm happy i'm getting the chance um good
i had a question about afghanistan so
since saudi arabia recently started
things that we're doing more progressive
not where we would want them to be
obviously but you know they're allowing
women to drive
do you think that if we never went into
afghanistan or if we left maybe 10 years
ago that
um they would
naturally progress towards
progressiveness as we see a lot of these
like more conservative countries tend to
do over the years and additionally what
major legislation would
you do with that money if we never went
into afghanistan or we left after maybe
10 years
well the second part is is you know
there's no specific legislation it's all
the things we've been talking about
already
that they love to say well how are we
going to pay for that they'd be saying
it anyway but you know we're talking
about expanding health care improving
education uh advancing alternative and
renewable energy the list would be the
same it's just we would have one more uh
one more sort of like uh uh tranche of
money available but they would still say
we we don't have the money to pay for it
in terms of whether afghanistan would
have sort of naturally on its own
um liberalized had we never gone in or
left 10 years ago it's an impossible
question i think it's it's completely
impossible to say there are some
countries where that has been the
direction and others where it hasn't but
i think what's important to know about
saudi arabia and i recently read a good
book about it about the rise of mohammed
bin salman is that
there's a big component of it that's
basically marketing and optics where
it's in order to be able to get
saudi arabia wants to diversify away
from oil
and they want to take the oil money and
invest elsewhere like in hollywood films
and then com startups tech startups etc
and in order to be better seen in that
world
they've done some of the liberalization
and so i'm not saying it's not in good
faith or that it is but i think there's
a big aspect of this that's to their
advantage for their financial goals and
so i have no idea in afghanistan it's a
very different situation but
i don't think we would be any worse off
had we left 10 12 14 16 18 years ago
yeah i mean i'd have preferred to see us
leave
maybe never have gone in but i don't
know i was too young to really
understand what was going on in that
time but thanks for taking my call i
love seeing people of the latin culture
represent themselves especially
after the changing census i'm really
excited to hear about that either and
last question what's your favorite
lesser-known mexican dish because mine
is uh
i don't know that i you know i i am not
fully a connoisseur of uh mexican food
so i don't know that i have anything
unique to really put forward there but i
like all of it thanks so much
all right thanks eva uh eva from boston
great to hear from her uh why don't we
go next to
uh there's just so many people here why
don't we try nathan from rhode island
nathan you are on the air what's going
on today hey david can you hear me
yes i can great so uh going back to the
pandemic um i have a question about the
future
sure um the washington post put out a
couple of weeks ago an article talking
about um how devastating future
pandemics could be the who in december
came out with a report saying future
pandemic should be even worse than this
one
um given that 1.7 or 1.7 million people
have died as a result of the pandemic
globally
um and we have cons considerable media
push uh uh presenting evidence of
individuals who have been anti-vaxx who
have been hospitalized and died some of
these have been uh republican and
conservative activists
my question to you is what do you think
it would take
for the typical anti-government folk to
take a national crisis seriously or
global crisis seriously if not not even
the individuals who are dying can
convince the people that they have
cultivated in these circles to
to move forward and get the vaccine
well what you have to understand is some
of these people are genuinely just
stupid people that's that's one aspect
of it
the there's a contingent here
that
it's not really even about the specifics
of the crisis it's just their
philosophy
is government shouldn't really be doing
stuff they see a government not doing
anything
as a good thing that's that's what they
want they they enjoy that they think
that that's what makes the most sense so
what you have to understand is it's not
really about even convincing them x is
serious
it's you have to disabuse them of the
ideology that starts at government
probably shouldn't do anything period
and that's a really difficult thing to
do which is why i and many others are
questioning whether we really have a
path out of this type of nonsense
yeah but do you to a degree do you
believe that there's a segment of that
population who are just the contrarians
who are who who are probably in a
community surrounded by people who are
like-minded like that and yes and so how
do we how do we convince the folks who
might have have a light of seeing
because because they you know they say
go vote they they advocate for or well
some of them advocate for policies not
recently but
you know they they seem like they they
understand that government has a place
even if they say oh i love small
government oh the government should be
the size of the bathtub or whatever be
able to be drowned in a bathtub they
their their actions speak that yes
government has a role how do we convince
them that
that public health specifically on a
societal level is one of the the
foundational aspects of a functioning
society and we've been doing i mean this
is um there's a few so so that's
it's really a more general question of
how do you convince people to re-examine
their beliefs so one one approach would
be
you
ask them in a sort of standard socratic
way
how they came to hold the general
philosophy about government that they
hold and then you show them that their
philosophy is compatible with public
health being a valid
area for government to be involved you
try to show them that you don't even
have to change your beliefs you just
need to understand that your beliefs
point to this is an area where
government should be involved because
it's too big for it to be dealt with
locally and it's you know whatever right
you kind of have to show them this is
one of those areas where government
should be involved with some people that
might work with others it's the personal
connection with some of them when
someone they know does get sick and or
die
that's what's going to do it there's no
one answer to that and that's what makes
it very difficult but all of these are
approaches that can work awesome i
appreciate your time thanks david
my pleasure i appreciate the call
it's it's an important question i just
wish there were
clearer answers right i think that's the
the difficulty
let's go next to jamie from las vegas
nevada
uh place with uh up until recently
extraordinarily high uh case positivity
jamie what's going on there
didn't get king henry
yes i can
awesome yeah so um me and my wife we did
get vaccinated
um
and i know if i do know if someone that
did not get vaccinated and they did
they did get the virus
yeah which is pretty devastating but you
know anti-mass anti-vaccines kind of
will put you there i guess
how sick did they get
yeah
so i just have a quick question really
um all right how do you really think
2024 will turn out
at the presidential level yes
i think it's too early to know uh so
much of it depends on what happens in
2022 and sort of the very brief outline
is if the people trump supports in 22
all do well and republicans take the
house there's a much better shot trump
runs and does well and maybe even is
unopposed in the republican primary if
the people trump supports lose or a
bunch of them do i think it'll really
weaken trump it'll diminish his power
within the party and you'll probably
start to see in 22 and 20 in 23 and the
early part of 24 uh republicans maybe
move away from trump and go in a
different direction so i think we just
don't have all the information yet that
we need in order to predict that
totally understandable and i think it'd
be shocking if uh trump would would even
be elected to get another term
i hope you're right but i fear that he
could i fear that he could because uh
his followers have shown that reality
and facts just don't affect them and so
i worry that he could get reelected
absolutely and do do you ever i don't
know if you have ever done this in the
past but would you ever consider like um
kind of going into more of like what the
meaning is of socialism like kind of you
know
going over that yes
we've we've done one long-form video
sort of about that we have another one
that's been scripted up and we're going
to be recording it really really soon
it's going to be about exactly that so
we have a big video probably a 15-20
minute video forthcoming on that yeah i
just know that you know fox news and
newsmax they totally
you know use that word and i don't think
they of course
they have no or at least they pretend
not to
oh yeah true for their their fan base
for their audience yeah exactly exactly
thank you for your time
all right appreciate it jamie from las
vegas great to hear from you a lot of
strong very very strong calls today
why don't we go next to
um how about jonathan from palm coast
florida what is palm coast florida is
that the gulf side or atlantic
from florida uh hello can you hear me
yeah where is palm coast uh palm coast
is between jacksonville and orlando
there i live in that area between oh is
it is it even on the water because
orlando's like in the middle isn't it uh
most likely it's like near jacksonville
okay so that's uh atlantic side right
yeah yeah
good good all right well what's going on
yeah i want to ask you a question about
the vaccine if it's okay
sure
uh well i took this two shots the
vaccine already i took the pfizer one
but uh
i wanted to ask you a question i'm not
fully vaccinated because i heard that
the fda is approving the third shot of
vaccine does that mean i'm not fully
vaccinated yet uh i i get confused with
what what they mean about
fda approved for third shot of vaccine
that's a great question okay so here's
the deal
right now what the fda has approved is a
two dose regimen meaning that 10 to 14
days after your second dose you're
considered fully vaccinated
separately from that there is now a
recommendation
for people to get a third dose eight
months after their second dose so when
did you get your second dose
uh at the 16 of august
good so you're considered fully
vaccinated
until april
of 2022 at that point you would be at
eight months and as of right now the
recommendation would be you get a third
dose then so there's nothing else you
have to do right now you are fully
vaccinated right now
oh okay
make sense
yeah right that good thank you for your
question david
all right no problem no thank you you
asked the question i'm giving the
answers here jonathan but i appreciate
the uh
opportunity
to uh to answer anyway very good okay
let's uh let's see who else we can talk
to here real quick how about um
how about colin from oregon colin you're
on the air
hi can you hear me okay
yes i can mr pacman it's good to talk to
you again um
education if that's okay um okay
listening to this
this long conversations with everybody
i'm concerned what do you think american
education needs to do to stop things
like people buying into conspiracy
theories people absorbing lies
what does the education system need to
do
to adjust our strategy because we're
kind of we're kind of too late now
we're going to have to do some
backpedaling a little bit but what can
we do yes how do we it depends on
different there's different problems
with different solutions there are some
school districts texas is famous for
this
where the curriculum
is just insanely politically biased and
it leads to people who come out of
school
um prone to all sorts of disastrous
beliefs because the the curriculum is
biased that's one problem and the
solution there is one
on the other hand there's lots of school
districts where
first of all the curriculum is just not
uh
rigorous enough in particular when it
comes to people understanding how to
think for themselves and so introducing
critical thinking
media literacy and probably philosophy
classes pretty early i would say
probably sixth or seventh grade if not
earlier
that would be uh important and
potentially a uh solution and then third
there are parts of the country and parts
of culture and society where education
itself is seen as liberal indoctrination
and so no matter what it is that is in
the curriculum
if that's your belief going in you're
going to resist it and that's going to
also lead to ignorance and people like
you say that buy into stuff so there's a
lot of different problems and the
solutions are not exactly the same for
all of the problems it's really
unfortunate because i'm a teacher and
i'm really just caught in the middle of
all this masked unmasked stuff you know
sure the florida governor's saying you
can't wear masks and then my governor is
saying you have to and i live in an area
where everyone's up in arms and everyone
thinks their freedoms are being and i'm
just dude i just i want to teach my kids
right now to be better than this
right right no it's i can't even imagine
how difficult that is and unfortunately
you're a cog in the wheel in this sense
right so you can all you can do is the
best possible job with the kids sitting
in front of you i i uh
uh your your guest mr cousin said that
there was a memo that came out about
donald trump jr said comparing educators
to the taliban and what do i look
for mr pakman i appreciate you thank you
for your time today
thank you appreciate it i i hear the
frustration in your voice there all
right thanks everybody who called in
that's going to do it for today we will
take calls again very soon and i hope to
hear from you then
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow all
right let's try something a little bit
different today instead of three
audience questions i'm going to run
through a few emails i've received over
the last
week or so really over the last few days
just respond give my thoughts this will
give us an opportunity to touch on a
bunch of different things and maybe
people will like it and encourage people
to send in sort of thoughtful questions
and anecdotes via email so let's start
this was a message i received from john
brown john brown wrote to me about
ivermectin saying hi david my
anti-vaccine uncle
told me he has the phone number for a
doctor in florida
who will prescribe ivermectin over the
phone i know i know i try to avoid him
but if i get covered i'm supposed to
call him and he'll call this quack for a
prescription thanks david best regards
john yeah so there's like three
different layers to this first of all
even the company that makes
cyphermechtin merck is saying uh this is
do not take take this for covid it
doesn't work for covet it's not approved
for covet do not take this for covet
that's number one number two
uh there are people who are getting this
from veterinarians because typically
in different
solutions
ivermectin is for treating worms in uh
various types of animals
elements of animals including
heifers and mares and stallions and this
type of thing and then three there are
some doctors who will prescribe it
um and then over the phone is just sort
of like you know on another level right
just sure take it here's a prescription
for ivermectin so i would be
extremely careful with that it seems
john has a good head on his shoulders
here and understands that this is not
something you want to be doing the
vaccine the vaccine is now fully fda
approved if what was holding you back
was there was not full fda approval
now there is okay so thanks john for
letting me know about that
tristan wrote to me on sunday
and said dear david i'm on a plane from
rome to new york
and multiple people uh including two
right next to my wife and two across the
way with masks under the mouth or just
off completely just unbelievable we have
no hope thinking it may be time to start
staying home again yeah
i flew back last week as many of you
guys know i flew uh lufthansa
and there were people all over the place
with no mask now i will commend the
lufthansa flight attendants
because like one one very angry guy
boarded
uh with no mask and complained about
where i had my luggage and was saying no
this is my seat your luggage should be
there and i said dude but we're at the
front of the plane
it's all empty there's room there's so
much room why does why does it matter
where my luggage is sat down was wearing
no mask within 30 seconds a flight
attendant came over and said sir sir did
you need me to um give you a mask and
the guy was annoyed and he said he had
been walking quickly whatever but right
away so a lot of it is it's incumbent
upon the flight attendants if they allow
people to not wear masks people are
going to not wear masks and i totally
understand
just saying i'm not going to travel for
the time being
but no surprise and you know my my
approach has been
it's it is really annoying to wear a
mask on a plane the entire time i get it
lufthansa in particular they didn't even
let me wear my comfortable mask they
gave me like a surgical one and the
bands behind my ears they're they're
rubbing and they're pulling i don't like
it but right now
if i'm choosing to fly
i'm going to play by the rules and the
rules are you keep your mask on and so
when they serve food i take it off i eat
and then i put it back on i'm not
playing any mask games
and that's the least we could uh expect
from people
uh okay a user a viewer named leo
uh sent me a message regarding jesse
peterson
saying david i'm a 76 year old canadian
living in ontario i happened to fall
upon a youtube clip of you on the jesse
peterson show
how you remain so calm under his barrage
of insane talking points i think he only
has eight puts you up there with saints
you are a brilliant journalist and
communicator never lower yourself to his
level again by being in the same room as
him please
sincerely leo yeah i appreciate that but
that that's not my approach i see those
appearances basically as performance art
um where i'm i'm just not taking it
seriously but i'm pretending to and
there were a few people who saw my
interview with mike pillow mike lindell
of my pillow a couple weeks ago and they
wrote to me and they were sort of upset
i wasn't yelling and screaming at
everything that mike was saying
um and i explained on air that that's
not really how those interviews work
well
it's not these are not people who are
even connected remotely to the real
world they're not gonna see reason so if
i just start arguing at every
opportunity the interview will go
nowhere uh and so my approach is to
pretend as though i'm taking it
seriously and just let them kind of
meme themselves
uh in into into oblivion and that's been
my approach not everybody likes it but
that was my approach with jessie lee
um and i thought it was quite a good
time i have to say i would actually
appear in his studio again
one of the funniest things and i've told
the story before was
when i went so first of all i don't even
know where to back up and start but so
jesse lee peterson has a studio and
counseling center in la
now
the term counselor is an unregulated
term you're not saying you're a
therapist where you have do you have a
psyd
or an lics w or
lmhc
counselor is sort of like coach
and what he does is it's basically like
a christian ministry coaching type thing
and he i guess has clients that go to
him for help so it's this whole
operation but the funniest part was the
staff on his show at least
not on the on the coaching ministry side
but on the on the show side they all
seem to be pretty big fans of the david
pakman show and a bunch of them asked
for pictures with me and whatnot so it
was actually kind of funny i don't even
know whether they take him seriously i
genuinely have no idea but it was quite
an experience and i would certainly be
willing to appear again okay also from
the email a viewer named andy wrote to
me and said hi david hope your vacation
went well and you enjoyed your break i
was hoping you could update us on the
arizona audit it seems to have fallen
away since all the crazy stuff that
happened in the last 10 days
thanks for your help and always speaking
the truth well nothing is going on with
the audit in the sense that it was never
really an audit
um it was effectively
uh
it was effectively just a pr thing
and you know at one point they were
looking for bamboo fibers on the ballots
which might be indicative of the ballots
having come from china
um they had a very powerful lights and
heat which they were going to inject the
ballots with or whatever terminology
they use it's always been a joke it was
never going to do anything so it's not a
surprise that like with many of these
things
it just kind of fades away and then you
don't hear about it again now there may
be some follow-up we may hear
some last-gasp effort to say something
like oh well somebody
they interfered or they only gave us
copies of the ballots not the originals
and so we weren't able to really do what
we were supposed to do or whatever so we
may hear about it again
um but we may not
and a real
sign of cults and cult-like thinking
that's very much like the kind of
apocalypse rapture type christianity
is that the date at which
something will happen keeps getting
pushed and pushed and pushed
and that's what's happening with the
trump reinstatement because remember i
mean go back to election day in november
of 2020. it was gonna first it was we
won
three days later media says joe biden
won then it becomes by december by safe
harbor day or whatever it was december
14th or something
this will have become trump's win
and then it was by january 6th and then
it was by january 20th and then it was
by march then it was april then it was
august 13th
we heard that now it's by the end of the
year um it's never i mean eventually
it'll just be maybe trump rums runs
again and if you want him to be
president you vote for the guy but it's
very very typical of cult behavior uh
we've interviewed in fact some of these
apocalyptic people where they say the
rapture is happening on may 5th
and then it doesn't and they say oh yeah
our leader miscalculated and also
mercury was in retrograde and alpha
centauri was five percent less visible
you know who the hell knows what and now
they have a new date it's typical not
surprising whatsoever
lastly throwing in just a little bit of
hate mail this is a viewer who has been
writing to me under two names susan and
chris they've probably sent us
i don't know maybe
150 emails over time
and everyone they always use ipads and
susan appeared in my email this week and
said
hey how's that joe joe biden of yours
doing
i'm thinking you're an argentinian
millennial ass
so not very substantive and that's
basically the gist of this viewer
who writes under two names susan
as well as chris
always the exact same syntax
always sent from ipad they share a last
name
so that is that
i would be glad and really thrilled to
include your emails in subsequent
segments like this one you can write
into info davidpakman.com and i hope to
include one of your emails soon also
make sure you sign up at joinpacman.com
because we do have the show
and then we have the bonus show and i
would love for you to watch or listen to
the award-winning
world famous bonus show one of many
member benefits when you sign up at
joiningpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com david pakman